[Music]
the song that reminds me of my family is
may the circle be unbroken we used to
sing that on road trips i don't even
know what that song is you're a real
church family i'm not much of a church
person we went on holidays and when
somebody died so if a lot of people die
like in rapid succession then i guess i
can call myself a church person
[Music]
piece of my heart is a song that
represents freedom to me because when i
first moved to new york the only chance
i was getting to sing was at karaoke
bars
and so i would sing piece of my heart
and rip my shirt and take shots and spit
them out on the people
and it was uh pretty magical at least
for me
oh it was magical for everyone i know
that for a fact
my song that is freedom
is you ought to know by alanis
morissette that's my other karaoke is it
really yes that was my karaoke oh my god
in fact it's my audition song whenever
you have to do a pop rock song musical
theater i'm so afraid of expressing
anger in life you know it's my own block
[Music]
you get to be so angry in that song you
get to scream feels good feels good to
be angry we're all hurting
we're all broken
man it's like the view
oh that's him get down
i love shooting in the car because that
was really when our characters i felt
like found each other they kind of found
each other exactly
and it was also fun to have sort of low
stakes stunts
[Music]
is driving a stunt
it was for me
don't hesitate don't hesitate don't
hesitate
i think one of my favorite things about
the show is like the the sweet
relationship between joel and sam and
you know when you're like finding a
friend and falling in love with your
friend
um that's what the car chase allows for
so i think it's really
very tender right
[Music]
you